hello everyone and welcome to another
video where i'm going to be teaching you
something very cool
uh and by something very cool i mean the
scandinavian defense or a certain line
of the scandinavian defense now after
uh pretty much the only uh opening video
i've ever done
on the evans gambit i've asked the
question
on my channel whether you guys would
enjoy more videos
of this kind where i'm just explaining
some openings and
a very high percentage of you said yes
it is 87
of you said that you would enjoy uh
learning more about uh certain openings
so
uh i i'm not gonna do these kinds of
videos very often maybe once a week
maybe
once in two weeks i don't know maybe
once a month uh we'll we'll see how it
goes but uh for today i've prepared for
you
a a wonderful uh well opening for black
the scandinavian defense
and for the first time ever on this
channel as i'm explaining on
the opening from black's perspective i'm
going to flip the board so we're going
to have the black pieces
on the other side so there we go i'm
going to have
the black pieces for this tutorial
whereas mr hoodie guy
will have the white pieces and now uh if
you're in if you haven't seen the
uh tutorial on the evans gambit it will
be the first link in the description
below
so do check that out as well if you're
only starting out
with some nice openings so here uh the
line i've prepared is the scandinavian
like i said
but not just any scandinavian but after
e4 and d5
which is the scandinavian defense uh
captures uh end captures with the queen
sorry about that uh knight to c3 we get
to uh pretty much the starting position
of the scandinavian defense uh sorry
knights to c3 uh the starting position
of the scandinavian defense your queen
is under attack
and here you have to decide what to do
now uh queen to a5 and queen to d8 are
the
most played moves here and when i was uh
starting out i remember learning about
the scandinavian defense i read
about the scandinavian in some books and
these were pretty much the only two
replies i didn't see any other
replies and only some two years ago i've
seen queen to d6 and i was very very
interested by this move
and ever since then i've been using it
in online play
i've even used it in over the board play
and uh it's a it's a very
fun opening to play so we're gonna
discuss the queen to d6 scandinavian
as you might have picked up uh from the
position on the thumbnail
so here uh white uh continues with the
d4
uh with the the well the most played
move
in this position by white and this is
what you're gonna play you're gonna play
in knight
to f6 uh white's gonna play knight to f3
and here you're gonna play a6 so this is
the setup you wanna remember
sometimes people play c6 uh pretty much
it depends on what you prefer i prefer
a6 so we're going to cover that so queen
d6 knight f6 and a6
uh this is your starting setup and here
g3 this is what white will usually play
because white will want to take
advantage of your oddly placed queen
so he wants to attack it somehow most of
the times and
since knight to b5 is out of the
question you've already played a6
white will uh more often than not play
g3 here and it makes sense it's a very
natural way to develop your pieces
you're going to play bishop g2 you're
going to castle
and then you have the f4 square guarded
by the pawn
so you can develop this piece with an
attack on the queen so this is what
white will
uh like 90 of the times play uh you're
going to continue developing
when playing this uh scandinavian you
will want to castle queen side so you
want to develop your queen side pieces
as soon as possible
bishop g4 you pin the knight white will
play bishop g2 and you're gonna go
knight to c6 so a very very natural way
to develop your pieces
white will castle and you're gonna
castle and this is basically where
where the fun starts so you've developed
your
entire queen side and you still have to
decide what to do with your king side
and how
how to develop it so here uh most of the
times white will go for bishop to f4 and
this is what we're going to cover but
just in case uh you uh decide to play
this and
you you encounter a different one i'm
gonna mention uh
two other moves that are that are very
likely to happen in this position so
sometimes your opponent might try
something like h3
and while you can capture for example
capture here uh
queen captures and now go for this queen
captures and d4 move
uh yes you've grabbed the pawn but
you've allowed the white a very strong
setup against your king you allow rook
to d1
so it's not not a very very uh
good for black especially if it's a
blitz game or something like that
you don't want to allow your opponent
like this so if h3 you're just going to
go back
bishop to h5 and then you're perfectly
fine of course if your opponent
continues with the g4
uh you're going to move the bishop back
bishop to g6 and the game continues
with you having constant pressure on
this spawn here
so uh aside from that h3 idea we said
that we were gonna cover another one so
h3 is possible uh so don't capture the
knight might be a bit too much to handle
uh d5 is another move you might
encounter a lot of times
not a lot but uh some of the time so
here you're going to go
95 and it's basically a capture fest ju
everything
just gets traded down uh your opponent
will most likely play bishop to f4
pin the knight but it doesn't matter
because knight captures an f3 comes with
check so your opponent has to react to
this bishop captures
you're gonna capture here or for a queen
trade because
it's favorable for you uh and after
queen captures here
now you play e5 and you are very happy
either your opponent moves the bishop
and you have a
beautiful pawn here or most likely your
opponent will capture the captures on e6
alpha song and then you're gonna capture
with the queen if rook f31 or something
attacking the queen you're gonna play
queen f5
now you have a lot of pressure here uh
the bishop cannot move the queen would
hang and it's
uh well it's a very nice position for
black to play and you will have a very
very
nice development bishop to e6 is coming
rook t8 is coming
and it's a perfectly fine position for
black so this is uh what you need to
consider
uh in this position after you know both
players finished castling so h3
is an idea you might encounter so keep
that in mind and d5 is also an idea uh
you you
might encounter but most likely you will
face bishop to f4 right away
and this forces you to deal with the
fact that your queen is somewhat exposed
here you still haven't had the
opportunity to push e5
uh and your king side is still a bit
undeveloped so it looks very scary
but it's actually perfectly fine for
black because here after this bishop to
f4 move
uh you're just gonna play queen to b4
and now your queen is out of the woods
you're very safe here and you still have
this pressure
on the spawn so white needs to find a
way how to deal with this
and white has plenty of ways to play
this position so we're just gonna cover
again three which are the most common uh
i will mention one uh
d5 is a very popular reply here uh but
i've actually played a classical game
over the board against the fide master
and i want a very nice game with the
black pieces after playing e5 here and
notice that
white cannot capture because the queen
hangs but this is exactly what my
opponent went for it was a
really interesting position so if you're
interested in seeing that
i will put a link to that in the
description below uh also it will be the
second link in the description below if
you want to
uh check out this line a bit further but
it's perfectly fine for black
you know nothing for you to worry about
and when i say nothing
i mean almost nothing so d5 is one of
the options that you're going to face
but you just reply with e5 and you're
perfectly fine and another
option you have to be worried about is
a3
a3 because your opponent wants you to
capture on b2 but you never want to
capture on b2 this is not why you played
the queen to b4
uh if you capture on b2 you might think
okay i can capture on b2 and get away
with it
no you can't no one can capture this
pawn and get away with it it's it's just
too much the bishop
and the rook will simply become too
powerful and you're just gonna have a
terrible game
uh so it it's not possible what you want
to play here and this is what you want
to remember
so a3 is met with queen to c4 and this
is where you're perfectly fine
uh your pieces are on optimal squares
and now
you will capture the d4 pawn there's
nothing white can do about it white can
either
white can basically decide whether he
wants to give it up here uh or
uh just allow knight capture so most
likely you'll see something like
h3 uh rook characters on d4 you're gonna
attack the queen and now queen to e1
guarding the bishop here and uh
now now you can play bishop characters
on f3 uh
or or better yet queen to e1 not queen
to c1 queen to e1
uh and now you're gonna see uh bishop
captures on f3 bishop captures and
now e5 here you're going to give up the
pawn uh
further your development you want to
start your development
uh as soon as possible or if you're
feeling adventurous you know if you're a
party person you might even consider
rook captures on f4
i mean it's uh it's a nice idea captures
and captures
uh you're now up to pawns but you're
down you're down the exchange so it's
possible to play this but
uh for example after characters captures
and queen e3 you're going to have to go
into
queens again queens and not queen queens
are off the board you're
gonna have to go into an end game and i
mean if you're
if you're a pawn person maybe this is
the uh the way to
uh play this position for you uh but if
you're not after let's say bishop
captures an f3
uh don't capture you can just give back
the pawn e5
and after bishop captures you're just
going to play knight captures on e5
queen captures and queen to c5 now and
this is how you finish development
because now if captures then you finally
capture and bring this bishop into the
game
you're well then you can bring the rook
into the game as well and if
let's say queen e3 you you just go back
again you offer a queen trade
and here white either trades or moves
the queen but
then you go bishop to d6 and now you're
perfectly fine you're gonna bring the
rook into the game
and everything is everything is fine
here for example if knight e4
uh attacking your queen you can just
trade captures captures
and yes white does have a lot of
pressure here but you are welcome
to play c6 uh block white's attack on
the b7 pawn
uh and you're gonna bring the rook into
the game next and so on uh
once you protect the queen side pawns so
these are the two moves uh you have to
be uh you know uh considerable off so uh
i'm just gonna return to the to the
beginning of the opening uh e4
and now we're gonna cover it once again
uh to reach that position just so
it sinks in a little better so d5 like i
said the scandinavian defense
captures captures knight c3 attacks the
queen queen d6 this is what this this
opening is about
d4 knight to f6 uh uh sorry
not knight to c6 knight to f6 and now
after knight to f3 we play a6 take away
the b5 square from white's knight g3
repairing bishop g2 and bishop to f4
we're gonna go bishop to g4
we have to develop our queen side as
soon as possible bishop g2 and now
knight to c6 and here we have castle's
castles
and now we discussed that h3 is possible
d5 is possible but that bishop to f4
will be
the most played move here and after
queen to b4 which is perfectly fine for
black
now uh you have to find something to
play for white so we said that the d5
doesn't really work because of e5
uh and we've now shown uh what happens
when it when a3 is played queen to c4
and
you can mess around with this position a
little bit it's a very very rich
position to play but basically
your main your main struggle is how to
uh
avoid losing the queen how not to get
checkmated and how to
how to develop your king side so this is
what you uh what you're most worried
about
but white can also play knight to e2 and
defend
the pawn this way so now it's defended
three times
and uh sorry three times and you don't
want to rush in uh
a russian to grab a pawn just yet for
example if you remove one of the
defenders
uh go bishop captures an f3 and grab the
pawn now
after captures and captures uh you're
gonna get queen to c1
so now you cannot sacrifice the rook
here uh to grab the pawn because the
queen
also defends it so uh you're not gonna
be able to capture the pawn
and here c3 is being threatened and now
you're
behind on time rook d8 you have to move
it uh c3 let's see queen to c5 and b4
and white's attack is uh coming along
you still haven't
done anything to develop your king side
the white has a beautiful bishop pair
here
it's fully operational and you have to
be very careful here queen c4 and now
white might even consider b5
and you know things are happening for
white and you're you're pretty much
stuck here
uh not developing your pieces at all for
example if cactus white can just bust
open with
with a4 uh b captures on a4 and now rook
to d1
and the white has full full development
captures captures
and it's a very very tough position for
black to play this pawn is hanging
and i mean you can defend it with b5 but
it's such an ugly position to play for
black
so uh after this uh knights the e2 move
you
you might want to consider before
capturing this and going for the pawn
right away so what you want to do here
is just play the very com e6 move also
knight to d5 is possible going after the
bishop
uh i would recommend you to try e6 but
if you're more of an id5 person you you
can also try that and see what happens
in your games
but e6 just prepares to you know develop
your king side and then
uh it's just gonna be a a nice game so
one
uh we're just gonna explore one of the
ways that this game can continue
so white will almost always play a3 here
because
a3 is uh pure poison uh against black in
this position you never
you never capture on b2 so you want to
move the queen you're gonna move the
queen to b5 and again
queen b5 with the reason of shifting the
queen to the queen side
uh sorry the king side in this in this
case and now
after let's say h3 challenging the the
bishop you're still going to capture
capture
and now move queen to f5 and now uh your
queen is not in the way of all of the
pawns uh
on that side of the board and uh well
you've moved the queen with tempo h3
pawn is under attack so white will have
to waste the move to to defend it
and only now will you play e5 and now
you're very happy
yeah your pawn advanced uh two squares
well not at once but the one square at a
time you can
develop the bishop and so on so here uh
white has to react it is of course this
is still impossible because the queen
hangs so you're going to move the bishop
and now a nice capture of s on d4
captures capture so you're going to play
captures a bishop will capture
and now you develop again with tempo at
bishop to c5 there's a double attack on
the bishop
of course you still cannot capture
because of this and after c3
let's say now you're gonna capture
capture and bring the rook into the game
and the black
finished development uh imagine this
ahead of white
so really really incredible stuff and
it's a it's a pretty dangerous position
uh but uh black black will hold this uh
uh well not not without much problems
but
uh there is no way for whites to
immediately take advantage of this or
uh to you know do do anything uh
yes white does have the open c file but
not it's not much to go on black will be
able to defend this
uh very easily and if you go for
something like queen b3
try and uh you know go after the the
black king right away
queen b5 uh takes uh takes it all away
not much to worry about here if queen
captures an f7
then there's even the rook d7 idea and
now uh the queen has
almost nowhere to go all of these
squares are covered the covered covered
covered and covered
so queen would have to go back and now
rookie two takes uh initiative away from
white and now it's black
black to play uh so this is uh
one of the lines that could happen but
it's uh it's very important to know what
to do in this position so this is
basically
the critical position after after your
queen is attacked and you play queen to
b4
uh several moves uh black uh white can
choose from
d5 uh like i said a3 also possible so
uh these are some of the some of the
moves that you'll see
but knight to e2 if white goes for this
then white knows what he's doing and
here you have to be very very very
careful so
uh uh yeah that's uh
that's it for for this uh short tutorial
on how to play this queen to d6
scandinavian uh
not a lot of things to consider of
course if for example after
let's say queen captures on d5 and let's
say something like
this happens uh h3 and now g3
white has a lot of other options white
can play h3 to prevent your bishop
from being developed the g for white can
also completely ignore the g3 plan and
play bishop to d3
but now that you know basic ideas behind
the white's strongest replies you will
very easily check online what happens if
white goes for a sub optimal
move and then you're going to be able to
to punish that and you know
come out on top even faster so yeah
i will also put some very interesting
links regarding this
opening in the description below so
first link the evan's gambit tutorial if
you haven't seen it the second game
uh me playing this uh game over the
board in a classical
uh chess game so you might want to check
that out as well
and also two games where magnus carlsen
employed this opening
so it's also played on the top level so
maybe you're gonna enjoy that as well so
uh these four links will be the first
thing you see in the description below
do check them out
uh so uh that's uh the second tutorial i
do hope you guys enjoyed it try playing
it
and you know tell me either in this
video or in
some of my other videos how you enjoyed
it and did you have any success with it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
and also
i would like to thank paolo veras
dimitra zaminski frank combs
jason baumgartner uh also known as push
shift and louis perrott for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
i already said uh the as usual stuff
so i do hope you guys enjoy it and uh
see you see you in the next video